a day ahead of schedule
prime minister scott morrison joined a
small group of australians first in line
to be vaccinated against covert 19
before a large-scale rollout on monday
what we're demonstrating today is our
confidence
i am supremely confident in the the
expert
process that has been led to get us to
this day
it's been a long time coming for
australians who've been watching the
fisa vaccine
roll out in other countries but with
australia in the envious position of
having few
covert 19 cases the government says it's
been focused on safety
the first phase of the program will
involve vaccinating health workers
and staff who work in quarantine
facilities
the first goal is protection the second
goal is to have as high
as possible a rate and we will learn
more as a world
about the impact in terms of preventing
transmission
although the evidence is increasingly
strong
the evidence may be strong but
government researchers found more than a
quarter of australians are unsure about
getting inoculated a day ago a few
thousand people protested against the
vaccine in different cities
at a time when the government is in a
public fight with facebook
which banned news content from its
australian sites
reducing the government's reach to share
information
about the importance of getting
vaccinated
taking the vaccine isn't mandatory but
the government is hoping to vaccinate
the majority of australians
by the end of october the rollout is a
huge logistical operation especially in
remote isolated communities
when the fisa vaccine needs to be stored
at minus
80 degrees celsius the astrazeneca
vaccine has also been approved by the
therapeutic goods administration
and is set to be rolled out from next
month but experts are warning
international borders could still remain
closed
for some time international borders and
public health responses
around international borders are coming
going to continue until we know a lot
more about how this vaccine is working
and the vast majority of the population
is vaccinated at least 60 000 doses of
the fisa vaccine are expected to be
administered in the coming week
with 4 million to receive the jab by
march
nicola gage al jazeera canberra